dr. Phil I need your help in a big big
way my family is in shambles it's been
worse than it's ever been
ever former Jackass star Bam Margera is
begging for help the 39 year old
professional skateboarder shared a
series of troubling videos to his
Instagram account on Sunday
citing different reasons why he wants
dr. Phil to intervene and help him clean
up his life et has reached out to reps
for Bam and dr. Phil first Bam says he's
having issues with his wife Nikki she's
stubborn as a matter of fact they've
printed five pages about stubborn and
she's to stop her treat stubborn he also
brought up their 18 month old son
Phoenix wolf I love him to death
and Nikki knows that and if we separate
I know she's gonna use them as bait and
I ain't playing that game so you could
happen next BAM says he's been at odds
with his mom April when I almost died
the other day it was super scary and my
buddy Lucia witnessed it and he called
my mom saying what happened and she
acted like the Phillies lost
it was unreal I have it on record I was
like phew forever mom I just heard that
and you acted with no emotion like it
happens every other Monday you are a
piece of work Pam also went on a lengthy
rant against his childhood friend and
frequent co-star Brandon Novak now that
he's all sober yes to love me from a
distance maybe he's the worst one of
them all if my mom he's the one that's
been pissing me off the most because now
that he's on his high horse nobody knows
that what he tells is complete white
lies Brandon commented on one of Bam's
photos writing in part quote we will not
condone your fatal behaviors
I refuse to high-five you to your grave
I love you and will do whatever it takes
to help you by the end of the video
series Bam acknowledges what he says are
his faults and again asks for help dr.
Phil I've seen 28 doctors I've been to
four rehabs when I went to my last rehab
more medication then I was on when I was
out the only person that I will believe
on the planet is dr. Phil in 2016
BAM appeared alongside his mother on
vh1's docu-series family therapy with
dr. Jenn where he discussed his
struggles with sobriety and mental
health
nine cars in the driveway and I don't
want any of it anymore like I just don't
want anything not like I was going to do
it or anything but I was like just send
me in that pool and make sure I don't
come back up